the 2021 juno awards which just
announced its star-studded lineup
of presenters and performers for its
50th anniversary
and carlos i believe you have some good
news for me
well then you're gonna love this cheryl
justin bieber will perform
to go along with his five nominations
now he hasn't performed at the juno
since singing baby back in 2010
and there's another big reason to tune
in on sunday june 6th on cbc
the show will also be welcoming back
country music royalty
with the one and only shania twain
i'm really thrilled because i'm gonna be
presenting an award so it's
especially exciting for me with all your
experience
up on stage are there any nerves that
are involved
i would say that there's always an
adrenaline before you
get in front of the camera or walk out
on a stage and i'm hyperactive anyway so
it can get over the top but it's a lot
of fun and joining the superstar for all
the fun
michael buble jessie reyes sarah
mclaughlin will arnett
justin bieber and first time nominee jp
sax
with girlfriend and collaborator julia
michaels
you come over and you stay tonight when
you won your first juno do you have a
very vivid memory
of that particular event i
instantly thought wow i wish my parents
could see this
i was quite emotional because my parents
weren't there to see the moment you know
i've been watching the junos
my whole childhood thinking
here we go this is what it feels like
so it was kind of one of those mixed
emotions feeling in that regard but
of course i was just really proud
and shania is proud to announce the
return of her las vegas residency
let's go at zappos theater at planet
hollywood resort and casino this
december
[Music]
tickets for the unforgettable show go on
sale june 1st
what are you feeling right now i'm
impatient
when we all get together again it's
gonna be the only thing i can think of
is explosive
it'll just be time to celebrate and let
loose and go nuts i mean i think that's
that's definitely what i'm gonna do